BRANDI HOUSE: Welcome
I'm Brandi House.
I am the product manager for
connected games at Unity.
And I'm joined today by three
of my friends and colleagues
from Google Cloud and Unity.
Today, we're going to
share a little bit more
about what we mean
by connected games
and how matchmaking fits into
that overall problem space.
Then Joseph will walk us
through an open match demo
and where the open
source project is today.
Then Caleb will do a
demonstration of custom match
functions and why
we believe these
will open up new kinds of
innovation in matchmaking
today.
And then Micah
will finish us off
with an overview of the Google
Cloud ecosystem for games.
So what do we mean
by connected games?
A few of you may have seen
me and Micah talk about this
before.
You know, it could be
single player games that
are more dynamic,
because they're
connected through
cloud features,
and it could be all the
way through to MMO spaces,
persistent games that
are always online.
And the way we think
about this space,
the further down the chart
you go, the more cumulative
the problem space is.
So you have more technology
and more design problems
that you have to solve
to be able to make
those kinds of games.
It just doesn't get easier.
It only gets harder
as you go down.
And what we've been
hearing from game devs
is that the real
time multiplayer
space and the
persistent world spaces
are still too hard and
too expensive and too
difficult to build, especially.
And really, the entire
space is something
that more and more devs
want to get connected to.
So today, we're focused
primarily on the real time
multiplayer stack.
And from what we've learned,
to make them successful,
to get the latency,
security, scale goals
that your game needs,
the tech stack really
needs to be a dedicated
game server topology, which
means that you have an
entire stack from the client
runtime, the networking code,
all the way up to the game
server hosting and management,
and all of your services
and how you connect all
of those pieces together.
So we've been collaborating
with our Google Cloud friends
to create new services
and new opportunities
for how we glue this
entire ecosystem together.
And specifically, today we want
to talk more about matchmaking.
We've heard from many developers
that this is actually still
one of the hardest unsolved
problems for games.
At its fundamental
level, you really
just need to take players
that are coming in
to play your game, form
quote unquote good groups,
and then connect them
to a game server.
It seems relatively simple.
But from what we've seen,
that definition of good
is actually quite subjective,
and it changes game to game.
You know, if it's
a more casual game,
you may care about
social graph distance.
If it's a hyper
competitive game,
you may care more and
more about skill matching.
And so being able to define
what good means for your game
is a surprisingly hard
problem, and there's not
been a ton of innovation in the
space, because so much of it
is still about how do I run a
scalable technology, as opposed
to how do I make this
a game design problem.
So from here, I'm
going to hand off
to Joseph, who will give
an update about Open
Match and the progress of the
open source collaboration we've
been working on.
JOSEPH: Thank you, Brandi.
Can we switch over
to the demo computer?
Great.
All right, so today, I'd
like to briefly highlight
some of the recent
things we've been
doing in Open Match in
the open source version.
I'll give you a little bit of
a preview of upcoming features.
So what you're looking at
right now is some metrics.
I have a proof of
concept matchmaker
that's running in
Kubernetes on Google Cloud.
I've seeded it with about
60,000 random players or so.
So this is pretty
similar to the demo
that we gave at Unite
Berlin last year.
If any of you have seen
that, it is on YouTube.
I highly recommend you watch it.
This one is a little
bit different.
It's sending four
requests at a time,
instead of one
request at a time you
can see it's churning through
about 10 loops per minute,
four requests per
loop, 10 or 11 loops.
So it's getting about
45 matchmaking loops
going per minute.
That's the bottom left hand.
The top right hand is
approximately how many players
are getting matched per minute.
Sorry, top left.
Top right is roughly how long
each request that's going up
against open match is taking.
You can see here they're taking
a little less than two seconds.
In the bottom right,
sort of shows you
how many of the requests are
actually finding a match.
You can see there's a red
line at the bottom showing
that nothing is not
finding a match right now.
So four requests at a
time is not particularly
high by Open Match standards.
What we really want
is to be able to get
a lot of concurrent processing
done simultaneously.
So let me bump this up
from four to about 400,
and we're going to see
what happens to the graphs.
Hopefully everything
should scale out smoothly.
The idea here is we're
going to slice up
the parts of the
player pool that we're
looking at into smaller
and smaller pieces
and look for a match
within each one of those
all at the same time
concurrently across lots
of processes in a
Kubernetes cluster.
So some recent work that
Unity has finished and then
contributed the design back
to the open source project
for making matchmaking functions
stay alive in the Kubernetes
cluster and not spin
down in between cycles,
so that you get much
lower latency matching
is really helping us bring
this to life right now.
So unfortunately,
my Grafana instance
is set to only refresh
every 30 seconds.
So we're going to have to
be slightly patient to see
the big numbers come up.
But hopefully, as
you can see here,
like we're able to
run a few hundred--
sometimes this will
get up over 1,000--
matchmaking
functions per minute.
And that's able to put,
you know, tens of thousands
of players through the
system per minute, finding
matches for them.
This is kind of more
about going wide.
Caleb is going to talk
a little bit later
about customizing the way that
you're looking for players
and trying to make each search
that you're doing go faster.
This is more about kicking
off as many searches
as you can at a time.
So the last thing I'd
bring your attention to,
in the bottom right,
you can see the red line
is starting to creep up now.
So what that signifies is in
certain parts of the player
population, we've found
every available match there.
So when we're looking in that
part of the player population,
for example, if you think
of like a tiered game
like a competitive shooter
like "Overwatch" or something
like that, this red
in the bottom corner
is representing like
your grandmasters
or your very low bronze
players, like we have found all
the potential matches for that.
There's not enough players
in the pool to make anymore
matches at that part
of the population.
So that's where that's
showing in the bottom.
Can we go back to the slides?
Great.
So now I'm going to
pass it over to Caleb,
and he's going to talk about
customizing those matchmaking
functions.
CALEB ATWOOD: Thank you, Joseph.
My name's Caleb.
I'm a technical lead on
matchmaking at Unity.
And we've been
working with Google
on Open Match from
the beginning.
We want to solve technically
challenging problems for game
developers and make
those solutions generally
available to game
developers at large.
In this case, as
Joseph was showing,
some of these
innovations are coming
in the form of services
infrastructure for matchmaking.
And so what makes Open Match--
here's the clicker-- such
a good fit for this problem
is that its core has this
highly customizable component
called Match Functions.
So we've been talking a little
bit about Match Functions,
but there's some examples
on the repository,
but not really a cohesive
guide for how to author one.
So over the next
couple of minutes,
I wanted to try and
demystify match functions
a little bit for you.
It helps to start with this--
a little bit of a
simplified services model
for how to think about
matchmaking services.
So on the left, you'll have your
game client with your players.
They'll broadcast to the
service a type of intent.
This could be thought
of as like a game mode,
some quality of service data.
It's a regional
game service where
your game servers are hosted.
These will go through
a front door, which
will provide the secured
data from some type
of persistent database.
Think like skill,
history, inventory.
These are things that you
don't really want the game
client to be trusted to submit.
At this point, the service will
package those up and send those
into the Open Match front door.
The Open Match
front door is really
good at indexing
that data, making
it highly available through a
query API for the actual Match
Functions.
We'll get to more on the
Match Functions in a second.
That's the blocks of
these blue blobs here.
What's nice is Open Match takes
care of kind of activating
those functions, handling the
cadence of those functions,
kind of as Joseph
was showing, we
can achieve this high breadth
of distributed processing.
And so you only have to worry
about this little atomic
component in that.
The end results of
a Match Function
is that it produces a
couple like proposals,
you can think of them.
Open Match resolves the
collision of proposals,
so if players appear in
more than one proposal,
it is a distributed
system after all,
Open Match will
actually give you
the ability to de-collide
those, and out the back end come
matches.
And so there's two
pieces to this.
One is understanding
the player data.
And then the other side
is the actual offering
of the Match Functions.
And so we'll start
with player data.
Scale is kind of the
super common candidate
for talking about this.
It's something we all have
a rudimentary sense for.
And while we're not going to
talk about skills specifically,
this is kind of just an example
of some distributed data
that you might have in
your-- or distribution
of data you would have in
your matchmaking system
at any given time.
And so from a match
function perspective,
we're talking
about segmentation.
So we're going to look at this.
When you're Match
Function activates,
you're going to want to take
like a slice of this data,
and not like the full--
like the middle
one is super tall.
There's a lot of
players in there.
So you'd even take a
smaller slice of that,
and the Match Function
is mostly going
to focus on taking those
10 to 100 players or so.
If you put those
together, arguably that
would be possibly a close match,
if it's pretty comprehensive
skill system.
And so if we move a
little further back,
we can start to identify kind
of the core set of player data
you're going to
need to be worried
about for like a basic
matchmaking experience.
And so on the top right
here, we have skill.
Below that is wait
time, which is
kind of an interesting one from
a Match Function perspective.
For this particular
metric, you might
want to have a Match
Function, for example,
that is going to
specifically focus
on the right side of this chart,
to find players that have been
waiting a long time for matches
and then specifically target
those players with
proposals that
have a higher urgency or
priority to provide those
back to Open Match.
Open Match provides
this evaluator concept
that allows you to
use that priority
to prefer those matches
over other matches
that players might
be appearing in.
So this helps solve for--
I don't have a deterministic
way to understand why players
aren't getting matches quickly.
Now, if you've worked in
a dedicated game server
architecture, on
the top left, you
recognize some of these numbers.
So these are going to be round
trip times to regional data
centers, where your
game servers can be ran.
This is super important
for matchmaking,
because you want to
take these players that
have an actual like
location on Earth.
They have that last mile they
have to be concerned about.
And so you can find
that common node
that they're all
going to connect
to get that tight,
low latency gameplay
that you want in your game.
So for a Match Function,
I could say, give me
players that have less
than 120 millisecond ping
to US West with
this slice of skill,
with an average wait time.
And if that produced eight
or 80 matches as proposals,
those would possibly be
like basic ideal matches.
But of course, this--
and this doesn't even
scratch the surface.
You have tens, hundreds,
thousands of data points
that you care about when
you're doing your matchmaking,
because good really does
depend on what you're
trying to do with your
game, whether it's
a social experience or a
super competitive experience,
so level, reputation,
attach, inventory.
One of my personal favorites
is current win streak.
So if I go into a game,
I've won nine games.
I'm going to go against a set of
players possibly who have also
won nine games in a row.
And so that's really
what Open Match
is trying to solve
is taking away
some of the technical
difficulties of running
a matchmaking service
and provide that sandbox
for creating a powerful,
custom way to bring
your players together.
So now we can talk
about actually
writing Match Functions.
This is by no means like a
prescriptive way to do this.
If you first get
started, though, I
have a suspicion they'll
mostly look in this form.
So step zero is to describe
your data, make your data,
and design it.
Anything that you can preempt as
an index going into Open Match,
that's definitely going
to be preferable to trying
to build that on runtime
out of segmentation
that you've been creating.
Then once you're in
the actual function
that you've been
activated, you'll
want to build and
run this query.
When you get back
your tickets, you'll
want to do some type
of optimization, most
algorithms between
two and three,
it's kind of whatever
you'd like to do.
A lot of algorithms will
have you like build hash maps
and do normalization on the
pool that you're actually
working with.
So you can kind of create
that richer algorithm.
Three, put the players together.
An example that
I'm going to show,
I just use a
bucketization mechanism,
where if the ticket fits into
a bucket, you go in the bucket.
And if there's not
room in the bucket,
you go in the next bucket.
And so it seems
kind of rudimentary,
but it actually shows a
pretty interesting result.
And the last thing you can do
inside of your match function
is you have an
opportunity to put
a little extra data in there.
So if the players asked
or have preferences
for the map they're
going to be on,
now might be a time that
you would want to, like,
roll the die and
actually assign what
map they're going to play
on, so that the server,
when it gets that information,
it's already configured.
And so with this completely
bespoke approach,
it really opens up a lot of
options that are sometimes
difficult to achieve with a
configuration or rules based
matchmaker.
For instance, I
mentioned rolling die,
combining your data
or making decisions
based on the population
you're working
with inside of that query.
So for example, I
query for skill,
but the confidence
of that skill isn't
very good for the
players I got back.
It's a new game.
I shipped a new mode.
I don't know how good they are.
At that point, I
could technically
switch to relying
on another metric
to try and figure out whether
or not this players should
play together.
And I can do that inside
of the same Match Function.
This is also a good
opportunity to inject something
like a social graph.
So if you have your
own social graph,
you could make a highly
performant off box call.
Has to be pretty quick.
We could try and resolve
interesting connections
that you can form out of the
population you're working with.
There we go.
All right, so if we can switch
over to the demo laptop.
So showing code
on stage is always
an interesting challenge.
I do my best not to show
just a huge mess of spaghetti
that's hard to grok.
So I apologize if some of these
functions seem very helpery,
but I think they kind of
highlight the lifecycle of what
a function might look like.
And so when you're writing
your Match Function,
you'll likely be working in
something like a harness.
Open Match, we're
working on providing
a whole suite of harnesses
for different languages
you're working with.
In this case, a lot of folks
who use Unity know C# and .NET,
so we have a harness
we're working with .NET.
In this case, it's this
configurable Match Function.
And as you can see, it
has this execute function.
This is your insurance
to your Match Function.
We will receive a kind of
context object from Open Match.
This will contain some
interesting information
about how it was
activated, some filters
that the back end created.
I have a query interface
for accessing my ticket data
and executing those queries
on those indexes I mentioned.
And then we have this custom
piece of configuration
that I've submitted through a
dev dashboard in the back end.
And so this will
mostly follow what
I was showing you a second ago.
We're going to
submit this query.
As I said, the context
contains these filters
that I've made on the back end.
I will collect my tickets.
And then these two
functions, which
are those helpery functions
I was talking about,
place tickets on teams is
just going to take a bucket.
If you fit, you
go in the bucket.
And then I'm going to
basically expand and make
a whole bunch of buckets.
For the second one
here, place teams
on proposals, my Match Function
is actually configurable.
That's what this is up here.
So depending on the
number of teams.
I want in this game, it will
then take as many buckets
as I need and collapse
those into a proposal.
So if I need 20, it'll take
20 buckets put them together.
Now, opportunity
for customization.
Before I put a ticket on a team,
there's an interesting gameplay
design that I want introduce.
My game is very creative,
collaborative game.
I like it when players
have an opportunity
to interact with people that
they like interacting with.
But in this
particular case, it's
a very collaborative
environment.
So I also want them
to identify folks
that they might not want to
keep playing with from session
to session.
And so into my
party concept, I've
introduced this idea of
a list of other parties
that I'd like to not
continue matchmaking with.
So in other words,
I was playing,
I had a great group going,
we were all talking,
and it's not that someone
wasn't collaborating.
They just weren't talking.
So I want to play with more
people who like talking.
So what I've done here
is I've introduced
a hash map of those party IDs.
And I simply de-collide
for these two here.
Am I avoided, so
does the party, team
I'm trying to match make into,
do they have players that don't
want to play with me, and do
I avoid them, so these will be
are their parties inside
that team that I have elected
not to want to play with.
And then we will take note
of some interesting metrics
when we actually
run this function.
And just to clarify,
this concept
isn't quite like reputation.
I'm not identifying people
in my community who are
quote unquote bad or poisonous.
This is kind of just a
self-elected mechanism
that your players can use to
avoid players that they just
don't want to play with.
And so because this
is just a function,
and I'm writing this right
next to my own game logic,
I can write unit tests for this.
I can mock my data layer.
I can verify that when I change
something, I don't regress.
And so this is a very
powerful way to test your,
like, matchmaking logic.
So here I've mocked
my ticket interface
with some memory data.
I have this function
that I'm calling
that just generates traffic.
In this case, I'm generating
10,000 tickets of randomly one
to four players on each ticket.
Now, in addition
to that, I'm also
generating one to 10
random other parties
that each ticket
is trying to avoid.
And so there's a
whole bunch of players
self-selecting into this
interesting game mechanic.
Now, here's that custom
config I mentioned.
In this case, I'm having 16
to 20 players on the team,
and there are four
teams per match.
And with this, I can
actually run this function,
and we can see how quickly
it executes and how it does.
Everyone can see that OK.
Great.
So as you can see,
there are 20,000 players
that we're currently
matchmaking in this pool.
Now, I have a filter here
for US West good ping.
So in other words,
I'm only going
to get players that are
near my US West data center.
4,000 tickets about
technically qualified.
It looks like only
one ticket wasn't
able to fit into a given match.
And I actually was able
to avoid eight match-ups
that if I hadn't done
anything, those players would
have been stuck playing
with players they
didn't want to play with again.
While this doesn't seem
like a high number,
this compounds over the
course of your game cycle.
If I'm able to avoid
eight every single loop
or 16 every single loop,
we're talking about thousands
of improved matches that day.
So the end results of this
was 400 proposals, which
are potential matches to Open
Match, which is quite a few.
And this only took 148
milliseconds to run.
Now there's some
optimizations that I
could make around my bucketing.
It's pretty-- not a particularly
advanced bucketing system.
But as long as you keep your
performance between here
and like a second or
so, you're looking
at a pretty quick matchmaking
turnover, especially
once you get distributed.
So that's the end of the code.
If I get back to
the demo slides.
Awesome, and so a
Multiplay matchmaking.
Built on Open Match, we've been
working on this handy service
that helps bring dedicated
game server developments
and scaling, but with that
super, powerful, and accessible
experience you've come
to expect from Unity.
We've developed this new
Multiplay matchmaking system,
so it fully integrates
Multiplay's phenomenal world
scaling technology.
It's still Open
Match at the core.
So you still get access to the
same customizable components,
like custom Match Functions
and custom configuration,
alongside that tooling
and lifecycle management
experience that'll be coming
to the Unity ecosystem.
Of course, it's a host service.
That means, you don't have
to worry about operations,
scaling, monitoring.
And because it's a service,
it's also engine agnostic.
So no matter where
you're coming from,
whether it's Unity
or something else,
you can get started with
Multiplay right away right.
With that, I will let Micah
talk more about the cloud gaming
ecosystem with GCP.
MICAH BAKER: Thank you, Caleb.
That was an awesome demo.
It's been fun watching
the evolution of Open
Match over the past year.
In Google Cloud, we
really believe strongly
in being engine agnostic,
platform agnostic.
So part of our
vision for gaming is
to make sure that you can
get your services running
and reach as many
players as possible.
So you may have seen the
announcement for Stadia
yesterday, which works really
well with Google Cloud.
But we're not only
powering Stadia.
We can power any games.
We're really ready
to scale up whatever
workloads are thrown at us.
If it's Stadia, we're on
the same private network
as those Stadia
instances, which is great,
because you can have
predictably low latency, really
great value with no internet
egress, and great data
security because that data
never gets onto the internet.
But having that infrastructure
hosted on Google Cloud
also enables you to
power the other platforms
that you're targeting
for your game.
We also have solutions
around data and analytics,
figuring out player
insights, like which
players are going to pay or
not pay in the next seven
days, which players
are going to leave
your game in the
next seven days,
lots of great
opportunities to figure out
how to optimize your game
and make a better experience.
We have a great
relationship with Unity,
and we really appreciate
our efforts together.
And our friends at Multiplay
have done some really amazing
work over the past 20 years.
We're excited to see
what they can do next.
So thank you very
much for joining us.
I'm waiting for my
slide to advance.
Sorry.
There we go.
If you want to get
involved in our community,
please jump into Open Match.
It's an open source community.
It's easy to get involved.
Maybe you just want
to ask some questions.
Join the Slack channel.
There's an email list if you're
just kind of poking around.
If you want to be a
contributor, you're
more than welcome to join
in and grab some issues.
We're excited to see
what the community wants
to do with this project.
And finally, a part of our
vision for Google in general
is to create, connect,
and scale your games.
And so we're bringing the
best of Google together.
And this is something you're
going to see a lot more from us
coming forward.
Thank you.